[Music]
case was dropped because it was a phony
case based on a false allegation
no one assaulted any Venezuelan woman
outside the embassy in fact it was the
the activists and the journalists
outside who were being assaulted by a
right-wing Venezuelan opposition that
was colluding with the u.s. Secret
Service in order to starve out group of
activists inside the embassy who are
defending international law against the
Trump administration's coup attempt I'm
not seeking retribution I'm seeking
justice and protection for other
journalists and activists like me
because it's really scary that someone
could be hauled out of their house by a
team of cops listed falsely as armed and
dangerous and then jailed for two days
and possibly put on trial because
someone who doesn't like their political
views decides to level a false
allegation against them this could
happen to anyone
The Secret Service certainly had to have
called an ambulance for the complainant
who made this false allegation that she
was injured the Secret Service were
communicating with one another during
this incident during the food delivery
they were present and what I think could
be the case here is that their concern
that their collusion with this
right-wing band of hooligans who were
used to do what the Secret Service was
legally forbidden from doing which was
preventing food and medicine from
getting into the embassy that it would
expose that that collusion and
embarrassed the Secret Service who are
themselves operating under the watch of
the State Department it's just highly
unusual that this would have disappeared
[Music]
you